IDEA IS COMING. THEY DON'T WANT
TO KNOW. JOINING US NOW, WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
SANDERS.
SARA, JUST YOUR GENERAL REACTION
TO ALL OF THIS FIRST.
YOU'RE BEING ATTACKED TODAY
ALSO.
>> I THINK THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
IS IN A GREAT POSITION.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING FOR
THE LAST 2 1/2 YEARS IS FINALLY
I THINK TOTALLY BEEN VINDICATED,
THE PRESIDENT IS COMPLETELY
EXONERATED, NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
I FIND IT ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS
THAT PEOPLE LIKE JAKE TAPPER YOU
SHOWED A CLIP A FEW MINUTES AGO
OF HIM SAYING I CAN'T BELIEVE
BARR HAS SAID NO COLLUSION SO
MANY TIMES WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
SAYING THAT THERE WAS COLLUSION
EVERY SINGLE DAY ALL DAY FOR THE
LAST 2 1/2 YEARS.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THE WAY THAT THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEHAVED.
AND FANNING L
AND FANNINGLY -- FRANKLY, THE
MELTDOWN WE SAW UNFOLD ON TV
TODAY IS TRULY ASTONISHING, A
GREAT DAY FOR AMERICA.
NOT JUST BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT
DAY FOR THE PRESIDENT, BUT IT'S
A GOOD THING WHEN CAN SAY THAT
NOT JUST THE PRESIDENT, NOT JUST
HIS CAMPAIGN, BUT NO AMERICAN IS
INVOLVED IN CO-LEWDING WITH THE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT AND A SAD DAY
IN AMERICA WHEN DEMOCRATS AND
MEMBERS OF THE LIBERAL MEDIA ARE
SAD IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
TO ME, THIS IS THE MOST MIND
BLOWING THING OF THIS.
THEY WOULD WANT SOMEONE FROM
THEIR OWN COUNTRY TO HAVE WORKED
WITH A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
TAKE DOWN THE PRESIDENT AND
INTERFERE WITH THE ELECTION.
THE SAD TRUTH IS, THE ONE THAT
WE'VE KNOWN ALL ALONG --
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE HAD A BETTER MESSAGE,
A BETTER VISION, AND HE
OUTWORKED HIS OPPONENT.
HE BEAT HILLARY CLINTON FAIR AND
SQUARE.
>> Sean: IT WAS FINE ON THE
CAMPAIGN, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MENTIONED IT, THEY FREAKED OUT,
THAT'S TRUE.
THEY USED THE DIRTY DOSSIER TO
GET IN THE BACK DOOR THROUGH
CARTER PAGE.
THEN YOU HAD STEPHON HALPER
WORKING ON WHAT HAVE OF THE DEEP
STATE AND GOING AFTER CARTER
PAGE AND SAM CLOVIS.
THE MEDIA IS ATTACKING YOU TODAY
BECAUSE I GUESS THE TESTIMONY
YOU GAVE YOU SAID THE FBI PEOPLE
YOU KNOW WERE -- WERE, I COULD
TELL YOU -- LET ME PUT IT THIS
WAY -- EVERY FBI RANK AND FILE
GUY, THE 99.9% I KNOW HAVE ALL
THANKED ME, BECAUSE THEY'RE
HURT -- THEIR -- THIS IS THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE WORLD.
JUST LIKE OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
SAME THING.
THE PREMIER INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IN THE WORLD.
THEY WERE HURT BY A FEW AT THE
TOP.
AND THEY'RE ANGRY ABOUT IT.
AND YOU SAID THAT BUT EXPLAIN?
>> LOOK, I ACKNOWLEDGED THAT I
HAD A SLIP OF THE TONGUE WHEN I
USED THE WORD "COUNTLESS," BUT
IT'S NOT UNTRUE.
AND CERTAINLY YOU JUST ECHOED
THE SENTIMENT AND THE POINT I
WAS MAKING IS THAT A NUMBER OF
BOTH CURRENT AND FORMER FBI
AGENTS AGREED WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
JAMES COMEY WAS A DISGRACED
LEAKER WHO TRIED TO POLITICIZE
AND UNDERMINE THE AGENCY HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO RUN.
FIRING JAMES COMEY REMAINS ONE
OF THE BEST DECISIONS THAT THE
PRESIDENT MADE.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, HE COULD
HAVE DONE IT SOONER AND MAYBE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER THING.
BUT ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
DECISION AND EVERY DAY SINCE
THAT HE'S PROVEN HE WAS RIGHT